[Musique]
la craie qui autant merci mon benjamin
qui sera avec nous demain d y entre et
au sein de l'équipe sera mon chéri très
bien alors greg guillotin c'est un
garçon voilà je vous le dis je suis fan
de ce mec il va faire un énorme carton
grecque et staff et mon chéri déjà je
peux faire un petit préambule
j'ai assuré fait l'essai de m'avoir
recruté parce que c'est vraiment un
excellent choix voilà parce que l'année
dernière chanter que l'émission bat est
un peu de lait lui avait soufflé est là
en fait là on va donner un petit vent
frais que ces messieurs sont révoltés la
dose de peps en fait et il a été comme
ça et que benjamin castaldi tout line
termes exactement en fait on a un pied
j'ai plusieurs chroniqueurs de
l'émission
oui grâce à lionel en fait ton collègue
cécile le radis faut que vous
rencontriez à un mec de youtube qui
s'appelle grec guillotin et qui va nous
aider à gérer l'image de l'émission sur
le web cette année est donc en fait je
suis fait passer pour un mec qui avaient
un boulot énorme et qu'il aura dit voilà
ce qui va pas dans ta carrière
comment tu ne le sais pas moi je vais
gérer un peu ton ta carrière parce que
tu es un peu dans le coup dans le creux
de la vague mais donc on a commencé à
l'épaule il répondu
regardez c'est la première partie de la
caméra cachée grec guillotin ballants à
castaldi c'est du très très en
concertation avec série b dont l'âge est
piégé les chroniqueurs de tpm paix avec
la complicité de lionel le bras droit de
cyril et david mon associé aujourd'hui
benjamin castaldi première partie l'idée
est qu'en dise et lionel effectivement
c'est que jeune filer un coup de main à
cyril pour rendre service
aujourd'hui vous êtes nombreux à vous
être dans le coup c'est pour ça que moi
en tant que star d'internet
il m'a dit voilà j'aimerais que tu ne
viennes où nous prodiguer un peu tes
conseils parce que certains à dire pour
un peu peine à voir
je vous prends rien du tout en gros moi
je suis là pour vous dire les gars c'est
bien ce que vous faites c'est pas bien
ce que vous faites si y'en a qui me
déplaît qui me déplaît je sors de
l'émission et toi aujourd'hui si je te
vois c'est que je considère que t'es
sauvé après tu dois connaître un peu les
grandes phases de ma carrière j'ai dû
voir pas mal ma tête c'est du tout
comment pas du tout bon jeu toujours
aussi du vif émoi jeu cartonne sur
internet comme j'ai pu le faire au cours
de ma carrière
l'idée c'est que toi tu fasses aussi les
bons choix donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
en trois temps c'est d'abord parce qu'il
va pas dans ta carrière deuxième temps
on va voir ce que je peux apporter et
troisième temps des propositions
concrètes
chose de projets digitaux qu'on va tu
exposes et moi je suis ici pour donner
un coup de pinceau à vos carrières s'il
ya des carrières boiteuse je peux aider
mais c'est pas pour autant que je vais
retaper la maison entière tu vois si la
maison est en ruine et tu vas quand
lionel il me parle de toi je me
documente je mets sur wiki et je me dis
ok castard hockey le mec il est
défraîchie mais avec deux trois coups de
pinceaux avec mon aide eh ben on peut
peut-être faire quelque chose pour lui
je vois que tu as commencé sur tf1 non
m6 est parvenu à les deux conneries tu
es mais n'a pas évoqué laisse moi juste
un minet merci en fait il n'ya pas quoi
elle pour rigoletto et yao qu'associé
mais si on veut avancer et tous et asie
le diamant m6 loft et où sa carte
tf1 est ok là tu auras casta il fait ses
preuves et après nrj 12 et bouquet final
equidia et la jalousie what the fuck me
rapprocher de la phase initiale
il ya des f1 est là et qu'il ya juste
prend juste la mesure de la situation et
des années que nous n'avions pas les
soins qu'ils aient pas autre chose et
desseauve guide ya parce que si j'aime
les chevaux étaient d'accord qu'on voit
quand même un quelqu'un qui dégringole
au fur et à mesure des billets achetés
chez les ados les dépenses quitte tf1
c'est un choix délibéré
on épinglera de secret story ouais c'est
pas qu'elle y crois tu vois c'est ça que
je veux dire harceler par les top10 a
été très bon la pratique mais je pense
qu'on a eu
la seconde informatique se sont
d'ailleurs assez mécontents
informatiques ont été mortels et je suis
bon test pour sa curiosité voir des
avancées mais dans le bonheur comprendre
les motivations du mec et moi j'aime
beaucoup mais je veux m'expliquer
déclaré j'espère que je tenais ma
reconnaissance que j'avais déjà fait un
joli coin des jets pas acquis les rendez
vous et on doit tout de suite des
tensions et franchement au piège était
ce parce que le rendez vous sonne bien
mais tu me dis qu'avec 300 des bouts de
casse les couilles devant lui et j'ai un
calme ne faut pas non plus trop me
cacher une coquette futur et je sais pas
ce que veut dire quel moment j'y vais
mais je dirais l'on peut pas ok flou
mais juste monnaie d'accord ok je
déroule donc l'heure qu'il est on plonge
les chalets pour réhausser ma carrière
qui était en quête qui est au bord du
gouffre janvier à mars est ok je suis
ces provinces et juste éprouve un tabac
et pas de portes au ciel froid et rendez
vous demain pour découvrir la deuxième
partie l'idée de prendre habré
évolutionnaire que j'ai proposé à
charlot j'ai eu un pitch que les
proposer en benjamins qui lui a bien plu
donc on verra demain
bon bah de gîtes avec nous de ben ouais
merci merci tellement rien que pour le
début oui mais ça chauffe avec nous
c'est qu'on est mieux payé cela n'est
pas pour autant qu'on fasse un bateau
bercy va me revoir merci motion ou non
après après pâques et toi merci bombe
règles allaient tout de suite